for the five nominated directors the
hard work is over it's been over for a
long time the only thing remaining is
the anxiety that comes with an
impossible night like tonight you five
have been singled out this evening
because you're rotten kids you're mean
and Scorsese has done a three-minute
clip to show your lives to everyone but
it really you've been singled out
because you've kept the faith with your
writers your actors and ultimately
yourself your ability to collaborate and
the courage of your instincts ensure
that your work will live long after the
awards ceremony tonight so here are the
nominees for best achievement in
directing Roberto Benigni
for life is beautiful Steven Spielberg
for Saving Private Ryan John Madden for
Shakespeare in Love
terrence malick with a thin red line
Peter we're for The Truman Show
and the Oscar goes to
Steven Spielberg
good and won the Oscar for Schindler's
List
thank you am I allowed to say I really
wanted this this is fantastic um let me
just turn my eyes to to mr. Hanks who
from the very very beginning said to me
this is going to be something
extraordinary we weren't really talking
about the film we were talking about the
experience of making Saving Private Ryan
and he was right it is one of the most
extraordinary events of all of our lives
the lives of all of our families we're
all in it together
Katie for putting up with how much I've
worried about this movie for the last 18
months thank you for for letting me be a
neurotic at home and and all my children
I have two kids here tonight and they've
never been to the Oscars before and I'm
really happy I had a chance to make Max
and feel proud of their dad and they're
sitting up there somewhere Thank You
kids very very much and my other kids at
home the kale industry and Sasha and
Sawyer and Jessica who is here too this
has just been an amazing experience and
what I'd like to do is just thank very
very sincerely the families who lost
sons in World War two I want to thank
the Nylund family and the Sullivan
families and I want to thank all the
families who incurred these tremendous
losses in this war we tried to show a
story of one such family and it turned
out that there were many such families
unfortunately and dad you're the
greatest thank you for showing me that
there is honor in looking back and
respecting the past I love you very much
this is for you
thank you